le bras des salades bio du jardin en
recul
c'est sans doute un des maires les moins
connus de lille dans une petite commune
dont on parle peu
un joli casse monsieur le maire ouais
c'est une vieille bâtisse de de plus de
100 ans maintenant daniel pauzé habite
l'ancienne maison d'abdelkrim le chef de
guerre du maroc
exilé à la réunion en 1926
le maire de trois bassins est aussi
éleveur le maire rassure ses pairs
là on est sur mon exploitation agricole
les trois pata pata d' kahn a reconnu
daniel pauzé travaille en famille
alors ici je suis plus chez moi chez
schéma ma fille deux des quatre filles
du maire se sont lancés avec lui dans
l'élevage depuis coulé mais on a encore
le temps ferme à toute l'entreprise
moi personnellement non justement j'ai
ma femme qui s'en occupe et baffie aussi
qui donne un coup de main dans les
commandes
les revenus ont changé aussi depuis que
vous voulez mais mes revenus agricoles
ont beaucoup changé c'est en chute libre
combien gagne comme maire alors je
touche mes 900 euros sur ces 1900 euros
daniel pauzé expliquent qu'ils gardent
1400 euros et qu'ils partagent le reste
avec ses adjoints mais il touche au 6900
euros en tant que vice président du tc
au vous deviez pas bien pourquoi une
d'argent non absolument pas et c'est
pour ça que je suis là
temporairement
9 heures daniel pauzé arrive à la mairie
[Musique]
oui ça va bien du monde
non je demande à tous les jours le maire
reçoit sans rendez vous
burlot mer mais rossa poids d'une âme et
c'est presque toujours le même type de
demande
emploi ou logement alors qu'est ce que
vous avez dit madame ma passion le
problème de l'emploi aujourd'hui
malheureusement battait contre le bo le
maire c'est un pur radio doléances ouais
c'est mario d'orio mais moi je suis
habitué mais plus difficile zordi non
moins de marge de manoeuvre
on a moins de marge de manoeuvre et qui
ment on avait plus de 2 200 contrats
aidés sur sur la commune aujourd'hui on
est à peine 1 à 60 alors on a perdu
100,40 contrant les visiteurs du matin
sont aussi les jeunes qui traînent
devant la mairie celui ci est un habitué
alors que ça n'arrive pas au loup vient
de finir un le jeune homme vient
d'achever un contrat aux services
techniques de la mairie
il faut aussi faire tourner un petit peu
que tout le monde en a un travail et les
bons mais mais malheureusement ne pourra
pas contrôler tout le monde oui allô oui
madame
alors ça va au fait c'est pour moi oui
parce que j'étais sur le tampon cette
femme vient de s'installer à
trois-bassins et elle a un problème de
ligne téléphonique
le maire promet de l'aider je passe à
vous voir si vous êtes ici bas niveau en
plus c'est comme ça que ça marche alors
[Rires]
si vraiment les dessous de la politique
là bas et pour le maire ça ne s'arrête
jamais quand il part des jeunes est une
femme l'interpellent au volant de sa
voiture la femme affirme qu'un adjoint
au maire lui avait promis un logement
l'après midi daniel pauzé nous emmène
chez un horticulteur des eaux et sur le
chemin la poussière vole car il n'a pas
plu depuis des semaines on pourrait
l'appeler chemin la poudre m'avait bien
dit et les tv velina du noir passe aux
marrons en fait notre temps nous fait de
l'oeil si on va commencer et natron
tendance à fritz a des liens et ses deux
fils cultive des fleurs sur plus de 6000
m² et les vendent un peu partout dans
l'île
mais leur problème celle où je suis dans
la zone by plus il plaît pas du tout
presque pas et bien nous on a toujours
des problèmes problèmes d'eau depuis 20
ans
le problème c'est que mon l'obligé
travail à l'eau potable penan un gros
coup même très prochainement nora de
l'eau brute que voir il veut pas en
parler o
le maire explique alors qu'un nouvel
approvisionnement est prévue ça tombe
bien
lou devrait arriver avant 2020 et des
prochaines élections municipales
bien nous allons commencer notre séance
de travail
18h30 début du conseil municipal
visiblement notre présence est un petit
événement pour une fois on a la chance
d'avoir la poisse à nos côtés car comme
d'habitude la place réservée à la presse
reste ce soir désespérément vide
à chaque fois on le dit à trois-bassins
petite commune intéresse personne
effectivement et à trois bassins
tout se passe sans grandes batailles
même de faire l'appel
merci car le maire sans étiquette a
rallié à lui la grande majorité des
conseillers son principal opposant
l'ancien maire ramakistin n'est
pratiquement jamais la pollution bruit
malheureusement pas son absence à chaque
fois ce soir encore daniel pauzé n'aura
personne en face de lui pour lui
apporter la contradiction travaux de
réhabilitation de l'hôtel de ville que
l'opération 400 milles pendant une heure
le maire égrène les propositions
budgétaires construction d'une salle
polyvalente ans et des études coûts
d'opération 160000 euros
quelques conseillers aux l'une ou
l'autre question observation
de la construction uniquement l'étude
mais l'ensemble des points du jour est
adopté à l'unanimité
pas de remarques qui est content qui
s'abstient merci à l'unanimité affaire
suivante
le programme est tellement passionnant
le suspense tellement haletant que le
seul internaute qui suivaient la
retransmission sur les réseaux sociaux
abandonne soudainement la partie donc le
conseil municipal de troyes bat ça
s'achève comme d'habitude il n'a pas
donné lieu à un spectacle palpitant mais
de nombreux maires de l'île rêverait
sans doute d'une telle tranquillité